hey there everyone we're about to show
you an interview with a mathematical
biologists called kit Yates
it's about coronavirus if you'd like to
see a longer version the full 28 minute
podcast I'll put that on the numberphile
- YouTube channel as I usually do and
you can also listen to the podcast in
all the usual ways just search for
numberphile and it's the episode called
Gondor calls for aid
so my name's kit Yates I'm a
mathematical biologists I'm also a
senior lecturer at the University of
Bath and so by mathematical biologists I
think people find that a bit of a
strange one to deal with because I think
people think that typically maths is
quite pure and abstract and biology is
pretty messy in real world and never the
twain shall meet
but I'm really what I do there today is
take biological systems that I think are
interesting so may be anything from a
swarm of locusts to the way that eggs
get their partnering all the way that
embryos develop and try and write down a
system of equations or computer code
which describe that to try and make
predictions about those systems kit you
say that people don't often see the link
between biological systems and
mathematics I feel like that's changed
pretty rapidly in the last few weeks
everyone is talking about exponential
growth about epidemic epidemiological
models about modeling and basic
reproduction numbers and I Boris Johnson
was talking about the fast upward tick
of the curve and yeah even Conor
McGregor I saw the other day was talking
about implementing harsh measures to
halt exponential growth of the disease
in Ireland so yeah everyone is there
everyone's talking about mathematical
biology at the moment so it's a good
time to be a mathematical biologists is
there a degree of that I know you I know
I'm sure if you had a magic wand you
would make this all go away and what a
terrible thing this is for the world but
our mathematicians kind of thinking at
last people get it I think that's true I
think people like there's a good mean
going round where it's just a guy
standing a chalkboard doing an
exponential curve and students saying
crap when are we ever going to need this
right and it's sort of the case it sort
of feels like to some extent a little
bit of vindication although yeah of
course um ideally you would wish it away
if you could do but yeah I think not
mathematicians are trying to make the
most of this opportunity and
and to try and show people why maths
really can be important it can be a
matter of life and death sometimes so do
you feel like this has shown up sort of
a problem with mathematical literacy or
do you think people have kind of risen
to the occasion and they're getting it
like how have you felt about how well
the public are understanding some of
these things before we do start talking
about the math yeah I think I think
people are doing an okay job actually I
think the fact that people are even
talking about it and caring about you
know how good these models are and
asking these questions is a really good
sign and I think it's it's a little bit
difficult to explain all the really
complex models that are out there at the
moment but I think that actually the
basic mathematical models that underlie
epidemiological spread are actually not
too difficult to understand in fairly a
fairly straightforward terms and I think
it's our job as maths communicators to
try and make those things as as
understandable as possible I think
there's a lot of good people out there
working really hard to do that
coronavirus let's deal with that for a
second that's exponential growth at the
moment yeah like so the way these not
the simplest mathematical
epidemiological models work is you bake
you you break the population down into
three different compartments they're
called susceptible so people who haven't
had the disease infective so people who
have the disease and can affect it other
people and then we have this removed
category it's sort of a euphemistic term
for people who have recovered but also
people have died as well this is the sir
model we hear talked about right this is
SAR but yes whatever you want to call it
really and we at the very early stages
you have a whole bunch of people who are
susceptible to the disease and very few
people who are infected and so each
individual can can go and in fact a
certain number of people who are
susceptible we call this the basic
reproduction number of the disease and
if that number of people that they in
fact over the course of their infectious
period is greater than one then their
own average in fact that many people who
will then go in effect that many people
again so covert at the moment and the
estimates of the basic reproduction
number but between one and a half and
four so it's quite a big window but 2.5
is generally sort of acceptable number
so the first person goes in effects two
and a half of the people they're going
to affect you
more on two and half more in there and
the the exponential growth then occurs
you get you start to see the numbers
growing exponentially what kind of jobs
are mathematicians doing at the moment
like I can see what I can see the job of
doctors and I can see that the job of
researchers trying to come up with
vaccines I mean the these graphs and
models you're talking about they've been
known long before
Kovac came along and that obviously
they're being applied now but are their
day-to-day things mathematicians can be
doing like new work they can be doing to
help in this battle yeah absolutely
could every disease is different right
and these these simple models that that
I've sort of described this SAR model
they can be made infinitely more complex
right so s IR is fine for some very
simple diseases but actually there's the
extensions that we can make to those SAR
models to include things like a courier
class so people who have the disease but
aren't necessarily showing symptoms so
they're not necessarily showing you
wouldn't class them as in fact 'ok so
you don't know they're infected yet but
they've had this asymptomatic period
which is what's happening with covert
and so they can be spreading it without
you even knowing that they're infected
and that can be that can be a real
problem it has been a real problem with
kobe because we can't just isolate
people as soon as they show symptoms we
have to be isolating everyone in case
they've got symptoms so that's just one
really simple extension you can make but
adding in things like noise so
stochasticity or randomness in the way
that people bump into each other taking
account of the networks with which
people interact with each other can make
a huge difference as well you get these
people who are social hubs and therefore
will spread the disease to lots of
people compared to people who are stuck
at home and don't go out so much so you
can make these things arbitrarily
complex and there's actually been a call
by the Royal Society for rapid
assistance and modeling pandemics we're
all mathematicians especially applied
mathematicians our familiarity with
modeling can sign up and help out in
this course to vo there's loads to be
done at the moment and we're keeping
really busy someone build in something
like these these you know these hub
super spreader type people as opposed to
people who are locked away like I see
that they exist but how would you put
them into a model these sort
and measurables or like I say you could
guess at what they are but then how do
you so they're not necessarily
unmeasurable so we actually know a lot a
lot about our social structure in part
from using social networking data ball
so just there's been a number of studies
done and you can actually classify the
way that people interact using the
network so people are noticing that
network and their connections that other
people are edges and so you can classify
what's called the degree distribution of
that network which tells you how many
people are there who have 100 contacts
how many people with 99-98 and so on how
dancer how many people are there with no
contacts and that distribution can tell
you a great deal about the way that
people interact so you can incorporate
that network modeling into these SAR
models so you know you start the disease
off in a particular node with you know a
particular connectivity how many people
did they actually interact with and you
see how it spreads around the network so
there they may seem almost intangible
but if we have a good enough data and
this is what it all comes down to really
if we have good enough data then we can
actually capture capture these behaviors
but data at the moment on this emerging
pandemic is really difficult to come by
I mean it seems pretty obvious that this
pandemics gonna leave a scar on the
world and have some kind of some kind of
long lasting effect
what about mathematically do you think
it's gonna have a mathematical legacy is
it gonna like because method because
I've never seen mathematics being talked
about so much global news of it yeah
exactly I think I hope it will draw
people into mathematics and make people
realize that you know you if you become
a mathematician you can have a real
impact on the world you're not just sat
behind the desk writing a textbook for
you know for a subject which is dead and
gone you're actually living in the real
world and you're doing things which can
have a real important impact on people's
lives so I hope that people future
generations of kids who are studying
maths in school the moment will say wow
this is actually this living breathing
exciting subject and I want to be part
of that and so I hope we'll get more
people into mathematics and I also hope
that people will take maths a little bit
more seriously themselves so math
generally only gets in the news when
it's you know the Fields Medal as times
and and you know people struggle to
understand the very complicated math so
that the Fields Medal
but actually you know at the moment we
can tell people about relatively
straightforward mathematical models
which are having a huge impact on their
everyday lives are suggesting how we
have come to this unprecedented lockdown
that we've never seen there we've never
seen before so yeah hopefully it'll have
a really big impact on people's lives
just to remind of the full 28 minute
podcast numberphile - also numberphile
comm or search numberphile on your
podcast player of choice I'll also put
some links in the video description to
some useful videos and information
including the numberphile video with Ben
sparks about the coronavirus curve and
great ones from some other creators as
well and just a quick numberphile update
before everything went into lockdown we
actually did manage to film lots and
lots of numberphile videos normal ones
not Skype calls we're editing them at
the moment and they'll be appearing in
your feeds very soon
thanks very much for watching and I hope
you are all staying really safe